Speaker 1: So unfortunately, we are going
very much the wrong direction in a lot of
ways in this country when it comes to just
common decency and, quite frankly, law and
order.
Now, I know that law and order is typically
a phrase weaponized by the right against the
left.
But we now have even Fox News host Tucker
Carlson talking about fake vaccination cards,
a card that looks like a real CDC card, saying
you've been vaccinated against covid, but
it's fake.
Tucker Carlson referring to these cards as
and those who get them as desperate acts by
good, law abiding people.
Now it's against the law.
So how do you call something that's against
the law law abiding?
It's weird.
We're going to look at the clip in a moment.
Daily Beast writing about it.
Tucker Carlson advocates for the unvaccinated
to get fake vaccine cards, quote, act of desperation.
Taking his criticism of vaccine mandates to
a whole new level, Tucker seemingly advocated
for unvaccinated people to obtain fake vaccination
cards, claiming it's not a serious crime,
but instead an act of desperation for law
abiding Americans who have been forced into
a corner.
Earlier this week, Manhattan D.A. Cyrus Vance
Jr. announced 15 people are now facing charges
over a conspiracy to forge covid-19 vaccine
cards and fraudulently enter people into New
York's vaccination database.
13 of the people charged for buying the bogus
cards are, quote, believed to work in front
line an essential employee settings, including
hospitals and nursing homes.
The scheme involved a forger who allegedly
advertised the sale of fake cards on her Instagram
account for 200 bucks apiece for another two
hundred and fifty dollars.
A Long Island nurse would then allegedly enter
the buyer's name into the New York State immunization
information system.
According to Vance's office, roughly 250 of
these cards were sold in an effort to avoid
vaccination mandates.
The article explains that Carlson has been
allowed vaccine skeptic has railed against
mandates that set all sorts of stuff.
So let's go to the video.
Here is Tucker Carlson.
Take a listen.
Speaker 2: Skeeter's so in good conscience,
they've risked their careers to preserve their
right to bodily autonomy and now they're in
jail for that.
Speaker 1: So understand that when you offer
a fake vaccine card to someone or you falsely
enter someone into a state's vaccination database,
Tucker is saying these are almost heroic people
taking a risk to preserve bodily autonomy.
These are crimes.
This is fraud.
That's what it is.
And they claim to be about law and order,
about, listen, this is the law now.
Speaker 2: These arrests will be used to justify
digital health passports for the entire American
population.
That is true.
Save this tape.
In fact, Cyrus Vance has already enlisted
big tech to help root out the disobedient
in New York.
Quote, We need companies like Facebook to
take action to prevent the fraud happening
on their platform.
Speaker 1: Now, even the use of the term disobedient
is just a loaded term, because what we're
talking about when people lie about vaccination
status is number one, it's a crime.
If it's a fake CDC card, you're using a federal
agent, you're fraudulently using a federal
agency SEAL as a crime.
But the use of the term disobedient is is
obviously cynical and tongue in cheek.
And it's meant to say these are people who
won't be bullied by the man
Speaker 2: said making, selling and purchasing
forged vaccination cards are serious crimes
with serious public
Speaker 1: safety concern.
There are certainly crimes, there's no doubt
about that.
Speaker 2: The quinces, end quote.
Except that's a lie.
Buying a fake vaccination card is not a quote,
serious crime.
It's not even close to a serious crime.
Buying a fake vaccination card is an act of
desperation by decent, law abiding Americans
who have been forced into a corner by tyrants.
Speaker 1: Now, quite literally, when you
commit a crime, you're not law abiding.
These are the people who say they hold the
principle of law and order above everything.
And he's essentially saying these are decent,
law abiding lawbreakers.
They are desperate and good people.
Speaker 2: You know, it's a serious crime
forcing Americans to take drugs they don't
need or want.
That's a very serious crime.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, that is a complete
mix up here.
That and and that is not actually what is
taking place.
Employers can say if you want to work here,
then you must be vaccinated.
If you want to shop here, the government can
say our employees can do the same.
There is even the legal argument based on
the 1995 case, Jacobson v. Massachusetts,
that the government could mandate vaccinations
more generally.
But that's not actually what has taken place.
Speaker 2: And let's hope in the end someone
is punished for it severely.
Speaker 1: Yeah, so Tucker's saying that it's
the people requiring vaccines that are the
people that should be punished, punished,
so buying fake vaccine cards violates the
law, that, by definition means you are not
law abiding.
Making and selling fake vaccine cards violates
the law.
That, by definition, means you are not law
abiding.
Now, Tucker has talked about this before,
about people who get fake papers to go someplace
that they wouldn't otherwise be allowed.
But he wasn't calling them law abiding then.
He was sort of using more muted language.
Now he's just going and saying it.
It's the Trump thing of what you're seeing
with your own eyes.
You can't or shouldn't believe these are law
abiding, but they're committing a crime.
They're breaking a law.
Here is the law that they are breaking.
But these are decent, law abiding people.
This is really scary stuff.
And of course, it's only going to encourage
more of it.
Now, with Joe Biden's federal employee vaccine
requirement, I can only imagine that these
people are going to go absolutely crazy.